prolonger l'espérance de vie des seniors
c'est l'objectif de l'entreprise blue
line et à elle propose des objets
connectés comme ce bracelet gps pour
accompagner les personnes âgées au
quotidien pourquoi aujourd'hui à des
gens qui vieillissent mieux que d'autres
alors c'est intéressant de suivre leur
activité de suivre leur présence et ça
suffit pas il faut aussi s'intéresser à
leur état psychologique
donc nous télé suivront des personnes
sur les actes et sur les aspects psycho
social et ainsi nous arrivons à
contribuer à ce que des personnes âgées
vieillissent mieux à leur domicile bien
évidemment l'entreprise propose aussi
des détecteurs de chute effet des suivis
du poids et de la température des
données directement envoyées à la
plateforme de blue line et à des
dispositifs déployés dans toute la
france et plus récemment en allemagne
en quatre ans nous avons vécu 9 100 % de
croissance de notre chiffre d'affaires
on est passé de 6 collaborateurs à une
petite centaine et nous avons nous
sommes passés de zéro client particulier
après dix sept mille alors chez nous la
dépendance ça n'existe pas la perte de
tonus n'existe pas nous on parle de
réussir à prolonger l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé des seniors
92% des personnes âgées de plus de 75
ans restent à leur domicile près de 1,3
millions de seniors sont dans une
situation de dépendance